me today we've got food fighters
nightmare mystery shopper tree taking
over the new one purifies nightmare not
sure the beard is going out again hmm
that were you gonna shave again ever I
promise mr. beard all right okay all
right pity what were you doing sleeping
right in front of me I don't even know
oh I'm not a man and all right perfect
okay pity this way I feel like it's the
fun oh you're losing your accent earlier
what are you talking about that it is
are you happy yeah that's better huh
what are you laughing at what I it's my
ex guffin Jesus Christ he's crazy he's
friggin psycho watch out for APD all
right I'm just gonna uh what are you do
I never got to huh with the footmen
twist nipples while going offline I'm
steamed which apparently doesn't work
okay all right that's weird
all right I hope too many people don't
spam me oh no I'm gonna do that way okay
here we go here we go here we go Oh Oh
take him take him up I'll dress these
people I know you don't pity seriously
though let's get him I don't Jesse why
am I so short or anything tall I don't
trust you not are you Adam look at me
look at me
what is it
No okay okay pity this way but seriously
though she's freaking psycho okay whoa
dude ever again take it huh it's my
competitors anything yep oh I hope with
this holy [ __ ] I can't believe this much
just be quiet fee don't make noises
you always make noises not the [ __ ] yeah
sorta let me down by the bed PD I'll
look for you okay huh why can't I go
fall fine there we go okay huh it's
coming back good holy [ __ ] okay shut up
now babe it's a giddy Shamu I mean Shamu
okay I sneak going away okay poppy they
run on three to the right one doh babe
[Music]
where's the follow oh [ __ ]
oh I always prefer I'm glad I'm glad it
was a favor
where's the fauna where's fauna swallow
did you take him yeah yeah I need your
fry are they alright
what the it's the follow he's like
really I'm stuck finish you have to
continue without me
oh wait wait wait wait not going
anywhere be there
I don't get you have to go now I'm not
go why did you throw that at maybe I
thought I wouldn't like to go I'm stuck
don't you get it don't you get you never
listen pity that's a problem with you
never freaking listen come on come on
come on boy
yes your ass okay I'm proud of you pity
I'm really proud of you let's get got
here alright still like well let's ah
alright let's try the other doors then
okay oh I'm glad you're with me though
this apana yes of course I am
that makes sense okay let's go here okay
this way PT I know I said it ah Scully
you guys can talk Paul I am okay hell
you could do this guy uh-huh
okay whatever well I here's key huh
all right I'm not a pump eyes piggy hey
what are you doing here piggy
wait were you peeking I don't know I'm
doing mr. [ __ ] it's been a while
I got piggy I'm so pumped I'm so freakin
pumped I'm on a fish pump all freaking
night me and you and me mr. chair
all right okay I need you mister okay
there we go
there we go put you down all right I
doubt my job I'm mr. chair and also many
keys wow that makes me happy pick the
room - this room's door you pick the key
thing hey Petey how are you doing it's
been a while you like me by the bed
maybe did you like when I do the balance
there it's my fat sounding you know
that's my fight this is how I penetrate
by the way
Thank You Siri interesting that's how I
do it I'm just saying it's like gay gay
just tell people how you penetrate are
you saying I'm the peg I mean look at me
I got me by the bed you you can't you
can't just say that you're not
interested I mean I'm right here laying
naked for you don't don't lie pity tell
me you're interested yes you can wink or
something you can do whatever not that's
not oh to be so I need it okay all right
let's go
have you gone no way that's not gonna
sell something yeah well I'm an I'm an
inanimate what the [ __ ]
I tell ya that oh [ __ ] man
okay okay okay where's the funny girl
are you okay let's go let's go Stephano
huh
cousin though it stopped dropping me P
this seriously it's pissing me off okay
where we going well it's so freakin nice
hey are you the fake Savannah no of
course not that's the fake Savannah
that's I don't even know how to explain
it
lame it's me ah I know it's my
ex-girlfriend she has like fake copies
of me she wants me but she why I won't
let her and she makes fake copies that's
that's pretty bad epic right there
that's biggest fan I ever seen yes just
imagine how big my you know is mine is
Picador just saying okay fine sure
whatever you say wow that's awesome hey
does he um you have a beard Scott yeah
of cars that guy you never noticed okay
holy crap beer that's awesome
oh gosh I'm French all French people
that [ __ ] Jesus Christ oh you don't
of course ate that okay wait I need to
find a key or something freakin Keys
everywhere okay but maybe it's hey
no no you got stuck
okay let's go anyone about a minute no I
think if the monster comes I'm gonna be
like no Savannah
hey Shh wait maybe he has the key
where's the key brah brah tell me
where's keys he is but damn it where the
okay s use the awesome big giant phone
and I love you I love you big giant fan
oh I don't care if you fake I love your
beard kübra
this is lava is there nowhere I can go
wait what is this I listen thank I am
there oh there's the key I told you I
was here just for you and you're not you
go to the fix the father I had the key
all along I freaking hate every day I
hate you so much
oh yeah okay fine fine fine would you go
I'm just kidding I was just kidding
okay this way PD sky ah no I didn't
realize I'm gonna take a bunch final huh
I don't know sweetie me miss me
alright good we good of course I miss
the cars
why is it so big she said okay what is
this I'm not touching your butt I'm just
gonna pick up the key alright Brock I'll
keep it in we need to go over here
hi am I going
we are you going we're in action got
stuff going off okay now take it [ __ ]
easy okay
don't do this rush like it always doing
so sick of still are wasting your
Lantern uh yeah
why do you sound like you're coming I'm
not coming I'm like oh my if you have to
meet darling back baby I'm saying
darling okay huh yeah it's pretty nice
alright that's about time I had for
today I hope you enjoy it and I'll share
with mark she defies nightmare I think
this call not good not a good time for
me everybody like appeared and all that
kind of stuff and
[Music]
okay